the day after a las vegas woman was
arrested and accused of starving and
neglecting her three horses the person
one who saved one is now sharing their
story it's been two years but she says
the animal is still recovering and she
hopes to help others catch similar
situations before they get this bad
sasha loftus live in studio with the
story you will only see on 8 news now
brian and denise the woman i spoke with
tells me her horse is still recovering
after all this time she said she wants
to see more action when it comes to all
animal cruelty cases
he's my best friend now a horse that's
been to hell and back is now living the
life he's always deserved
meet zeke you'd never know it now but he
used to look like this after his adopter
who didn't want to share her identity
saved him two years ago nothing was
taken care of he was still underweight
when he came home she says he was one of
three horses starved for months in the
northeast valley his hips were sticking
out like no other he was moving slow at
first
he didn't want to get up armalinda roca
was arrested this week accused of
keeping zeke and two other horses in
filthy conditions
with algae covered water buckets and no
food as far as i know he was pretty much
up to his belly and feces and
that's all he only had his feces to eat
it was a long difficult road his current
family wishes zeke never had to face
but with their love and daily dedication
he's now doing his best to embrace his
second chance at happiness he's still
not over anything
but he's getting there and he's getting
better by the day and slowly understands
he'll never have to no hunger fear or
pain ever again he knows he's going to
be fed he knows that it's not going to
stop again
zeke and the two other horses were
rescued in 2020 one of them later died
irmalinda roca faces three felony
charges for wilford on malicious torture
of an animal she was released on her own
recognizance and ordered not to have
contact with animals she's due back in
court on august 9. denise